o psol e 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer uma faca do papel que é mais
conhecida pelo nome de kan bits
ela ficou bastante popular por causa do
jogo contra o cilic
eu vou ensinar como fazer uma versão
bastante simples e também resistentes
para começar tem que usar uma folha com
se fosse um rio
caso vocês não conseguirão fazer isso
direito e deixar um link na descrição
ensina a fazer isso mas lugar passa paz
para que deixei lá um pouco larga
permitindo assim espalmá-la depois ao
total vão precisar de quatro reforços
moda deste modo em que vão deixar uma
parte circular no maio depois de fazerem
isso tem que colar as partes ficaram
feitas para circular tem que permitir
que você se encaixem no mínimo dois
litros tem que dar essa curvatura uma
vez que é carambeí tema facas encurvada
que faz com que o triângulo à frente
também tem que ser uma coisa bem
pequenina que é o triângulo caí curva em
uma rifa deste modo e cola no lugar
assinalado quando tiver sei que sou
colar também ali porque no triângulo
por força a esta parte assim para ficar
na ponta mais tempo
e vejam porque são vocês da obra onde
acaba a parte de baixo do carro
agora é só colar as partes todas de modo
a fazer um retângulo
isso vai dar resistência ao cabo da faca
é bastante cola e em caixinha parte das
minha parte mais frágil e façam isso
porque no nosso vocês quiserem fica mais
bonita e é bastante simples fazer tem
que abraçar o resto rifa da curvatura
assim voltando aos poucos ao cair
espero que será depois mais um cadinho
espera crescer pois mais um pitching
faça mais isso na hora do im que deixa
bastante mais bonita depois fazer o
molde tem que estar o resto do planeta
se vocês quiserem podem pôr mais gente
faz para fazer uma lâmina mais compacta
e pronto já está foi isso aí só espero
que tenham gostado se vocês quiserem da
canal extra charlie que se inscrevam
carlos alves critica isso vai pedir ao
tre e amanhã